[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello
again, everyone.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Tim!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So welcome to
day two of the Ubiquity Dev
Summit.
Before we begin, I'd like
to speak a little bit
about building across devices.
Now, some of you have
heard this before.
If you have, please forgive me.
For those of you
that are new to it,
it's just a simple outline
of why and how to think
about building across devices.
You see, ubiquitous
computing is just
a fancy phrase for technology
that's accessible to the user
whenever and wherever they want.
Right?
We talked a lot about
that on day one.
Well, here's just a
little bit more detail.
Imagine your users
wherever they might be.
Right?
They might be
having some friends
over watching cat
videos and playing
video games in the living room.
They're outside going
for a bike ride.
Or maybe it's time
for a road trip.
You're going to want to
make sure that in any
of these situations that your
users can access your service.
You don't want this where it's
like, which device do I go to?
Instead, you want it
available on any device
that they might have at hand.
And this is what we mean
by ubiquitous computing.
And these as devices, the
number of them is staggering.
So you as a developer are
thinking about all the places
your users can go
to for your service.
It's a pretty large number.
In fact, this study by Intel
says 200 billion in 2020.
Or as Gayathri put it the
other day, 26 connected devices
for every person on the planet.
Now, not all of these
are in their pocket.
Right?
Some of these are
spread across the world.
But a handful of these are
associated with their users.
And that's a ton of smart
devices in the world.
And another number
that you really
should keep in mind,
especially if you're a startup,
is that half of the
solutions for IoT
are going to be from startups
less than three years old.
Half!
That's just a really big number.
So the question
really is have you
started building for
this reality already?
And the good news is that it's
not as hard as it might seem.
Right?
What I'd like to leave
you with is this idea
of building across these
devices as a holistic approach
for your app and your service.
Right?
And you can think less about
having say a single service
for each device.
Here's an example of
that architecture.
Now the traditional approach
is for different devices
to make an app for each
device as these devices become
available to the users.
And this is, I mean,
this is kind of crazy.
It's typically
meant a new project
for each device developed
and supported independently,
a new engineering team
in your company often.
And the ironic thing
is that most of us
already think about this whole
experience as one experience.
Right?
So building it as separate
apps, separate projects,
separate products is just
the wrong way to go about it.
What you want to
think about it is
having a single app and
each of these devices
as a view into that service.
And again, this
is really what we
think about when we think
about ubiquitous computing.
This is the model.
Right?
Is your service wherever the
user might want or need it?
And then also
reducing this equation
so you don't have
to think so much
about the technical
implementation or the glue
in between these apps.
But you're just
thinking about what's
the right thing on
each form factor
for the user in that context.
And that's how we're trying to
build our platform so that you
can go from one
device to the other
by just extending it with
a few additional APIs.
And we're going to
talk about those today.
We're going to talk first about
the living room with Rishi
Chandra, vice president of
product management for Google
Cast and Android TV.
Rishi.
RISHI CHANDRA: Thank you.
Good morning.
So today I'm going to talk
to you about the living room.
But actually, it's going to be
a little bit more than that.
The living room is just
one room of where consumers
consume entertainment.
Ultimately it's about the
home and home entertainment.
That's really how we're
looking at this opportunity.
And the opportunity
is pretty immense.
It's estimated that
50% of all audio
is actually consumed
in the home.
And if you look
at TV consumption,
you'd think it's going
down, but it hasn't.
It's still more than four hours
a day per household in the US,
and more than three
hours a day globally.
So there's an
immense opportunity
to reach consumers
where they are actually
spending their
time and consuming
entertainment and
applications and experiences.
So today what I
wanted to do is talk
a little bit about how
Google sees the living room
opportunity.
and more particularly a home
entertainment opportunity.
And we'll start with a
couple trends that we see
and then how we're looking
at building platforms
so that developers
can take advantage
of this immense opportunity
in people's homes.
So let me start with the first
opportunity, or first trend we
see, which actually
seems obvious now,
but wasn't that obvious
just 18 months ago, which
is the content world
is transitioning
to an online distribution world.
And this is really,
really important
because historically, the
content that you had access to
in the home was actually
very siloed and very limited.
You had a limited
choice, and now you're
moving to unlimited choice.
You had a generic
set of content,
and now you have
personalized content.
And before you can only view
it on a single, specific device
in one room in your house.
And now you can view it
anywhere across any device.
It's a major transformation
that's happening.
And it's particularly
impacting the home.
So the content
industry is leading
the way, driven by consumers
who are demanding this access.
But what hasn't yet
caught up are the devices
that you actually consume
this in your home--
the speakers and
your televisions.
And so there's a
really big opportunity
of how we can rethink the
experience of these devices,
bringing applications, bringing
new services that never were
there before, and opening up
an opportunity so that you
can actually innovate where you
could never innovate before.
There's a really
interesting time.
And now is the right time.
I mean, just last
year, the new services
that are being launched
with an over the top way
opens up a lot of new engagement
opportunities within the home.
And so I think this
is the perfect time
to be looking at the living
room as an immense opportunity
that you could
take advantage of.
The second trend is
a little more subtle,
which is that we're shifting
from how you actually
interact with your home
entertainment devices.
Historically, it's been through
the directional pattern which
was invented 40, 50 years ago.
And it's really simple, but
it's also very limiting.
And what we're finding is that
this shift is happening today
where the mobile
device is becoming
increasingly the center
of your digital life.
Where it has a much more
powerful processing power.
It has a lot more capabilities
with the touch screen.
It's more personalized.
It's where you're already
organizing your life.
So whether you're at home
or at work or in the car,
consumers want to have the
same experience now when
they're coming home.
And so we're seeing
that the mobile phone
is becoming a really
increasing part of that center
of your digital life.
And the reality of
how you're going
to start interacting with
all these different devices
in the home today.
So it gives a new opportunity.
We need to rethink how
does a mobile phone
play into these
entertain experiences?
And how does it play with
all your different devices?
Now not everyone's going
make this shift right away.
Some consumers have
already made the shift,
some obviously still
recognize that they prefer
the traditional remote control.
But we do see a shift happening.
So, those two
insights really drove
the product definition for
the first product we launched
called Chromecast in July 2013.
It was optimized for this world.
It's the first the mobile
first online distribution
based product where we can
deliver an amazing user
experience around that use case.
And we're really happy with it.
We started with four apps
when we launched Chromecast.
And now we have
thousands of apps.
We have over 20 million
devices sold in a little
over two years of the
product being launched.
And we have over
three billion presses
of the Cast button-- those are
each opportunity of engagement
that consumers had with a
content app on the big screen.
So we see a lot of momentum
there and it's really based off
this simple idea of how do we
bring a mobile first experience
to the living room.
In September, we
actually updated,
we refreshed the product
by improving the Chromecast
with better Wi-Fi
capability and better speed.
But we also launched
another version
of the Chromecast,
Chromecast Audio.
So similar to how Chromecast
takes your existing smart TVs--
or existing TVs and
make them smart--
Chromecast Audio can take
your existing speakers
and make them smart as well.
And we're just really
excited at the momentum
we're seeing both on Chromecast
and Chromecast Audio.
But, obviously the
opportunity of the living room
is much bigger than just
a single point product.
Our ultimate goal with the
platforms that we're creating
is to help developers connect
all their amazing content
with all the different
devices that a consumer can
have in their home today.
So we started with
streaming devices
with Chromecast and
Chromecast Audio.
But ultimately, we want to
be embedded in televisions,
in every speaker in your home,
and even your set-top boxes
that you may get from your
operator, your TV operator.
As many devices,
we want to touch
the one billion households
that have home entertainment
devices.
We need to think bigger.
And that's why Google has two
great platforms for how we're
approaching the living room.
And there's a reason
why we have two.
We started with Google Cast,
which is the technology
that powers Chromecast.
And that's really based off
this mobile centric world.
Make it incredibly easy
to take your existing
iOS app, your existing Android
app, or existing web page, web
app, and extend it to all
these different devices.
But like I mentioned
before we recognize
there are a set of
consumers out there
who haven't yet
got mobile first.
And they still want to have
all the great capabilities
that a rich platform can enable.
And that's really why we
launched Android TV in 2014.
It takes the Android
operating system, embeds it
into a whole host of
different devices,
and now you can take
your mobile Android app
and bridge it and extend it
to the television as well.
So consumers can have a
traditional experience
with a remote control, but also
run great, powerful, native
applications.
And we're going to continue to
invest in both these platforms
to make them really the
de facto way that you can
engage all the different devices
that you'd see in a home today.
But of course, Google's approach
is always about ecosystems.
So we also don't think of
this as just a point product
that Google's going to build.
We're really happy with
the success of Chromecast.
It's built by Google,
designed by Google,
marketed and
distributed by Google.
But ultimately, we're
not going to touch
a billion different
households with one product
from Google or two
products from Google.
We have to think bigger
in terms of an ecosystem.
And so it's really
important for us
to build partnerships
with the OEM community.
And this is really what made
Android really successful.
This is what got
us to the billion
different mobile devices.
And so we've been
spending a lot of time
as part of a living
room strategy
to really think about how do
we engage with OEMs and device
manufacturers in a really
compelling and deep way.
And we see a lot of success
over the last 18 months.
So smart TVs, we want to
make sure that if you ever
buy a new TV, that you have
Google technology built
into it, whether it be Android
TV which also then includes
Google Cast.
So we launched last year
Android TV with Sony.
They announced last CES
and had a great year
selling televisions.
And just this past
week, I was at CES
and they talked about all
the new sets of devices
they have built an Android TV.
Really compelling, great story.
There's a whole host
of new TV manufacturers
that we're embedding
into as well
that you'll see over
the next few months.
In the speaker market,
we want to make sure
that any speaker you
have that you buy
will have Google
Cast built into it.
So we partnered last
year with Sony and LG
and they launched a whole
bunch of sound bars,
avrs, wireless speakers, with
Google Cast technology built
in.
And now we've announced last
week a whole host of new OEMs
as well.
Ultimately, you'll
see the products
over the next,
again, six months.
But we're really excited
to see the momentum
around really Google Cast as
being a de facto way that you
can bring great services and
applications to these speaker
devices.
And then the last category
is pay TV set-top boxes.
Every operator you get,
these are the operator boxes
you get when you sign
up for TV service.
They'll actually bring
your a device in your home
that you can use to connect
to your linear TV service.
Every one of these
operators today
is looking at this
changing environment
of what's happening
in the industry
and looking at
refreshing their devices.
So how can they
bring compelling sets
of applications on top of their
TV service they have today.
And so we've been partnering
with a whole host of them
so that as consumers are
getting upgraded to new devices
and boxes in their home,
they're automatically
getting a platform that is
rich and compelling based
off Android TV and having Google
Cast built into it as well.
We think we have the
only strategy which
includes both point
products built by Google,
but also a really wide set
of partnerships with OEMs
to really build a scalable
model so that developers like
you can actually build
awesome experiences on top
of a wide range of devices.
It's the only way we're
going to get scale
to make it really impactful
for the consumers.
So now let's talk about
the technology themselves.
So we start with
the Google Cast SDK.
This is the development Kit
that allows you to take, again,
your existing Android,
iOS, or web app
and extend it to your TV.
It's a really simple model.
You embed it in the existing
app you're already in,
that you already
own, and all you
do is enable the Cast button and
now you can actually extend it
to another device.
The power for this
is for consumers,
they don't have to
learn anything new.
If they already use Spotify, for
example, in their daily lives,
then all they're
going to see now
is a button to now use
Spotify to extend it
to their speakers or TVs.
Or Netflix, or
YouTube, what have you.
It's a really simple
development model.
And from a developer's
standpoint, all you need to do
is embed the Cast
SDK and have some way
to actually render
the content, which
we'll take care of for you.
So it's really simple,
easy development model.
It allows any app developer,
any media based app developer
to extend their content in
a really easy, simple way.
Now we're continuing
to innovate on the SDK.
Last year, in conjunction with
the Chromecast Audio launch,
we launched audio support.
So you can have an audio
only mode for your content
so it can work on
devices like speakers.
And what was really exciting,
we launched multi-room support
last December.
This allows you to
synchronize your audio
across multiple different rooms
in the home, any device that
has a Chromecast Audio in it.
It works really well.
If you haven't tried it
out, please try it out.
It's amazing value for a
product that's only $35.
And we're going to be,
just like I mentioned
before on the
ecosystem, we're going
to extending that capability
to the ecosystem as well.
So whether you get
a Sony AVR and you
want to pair it
with a JBL speaker,
you can do that using
the Cast SDK to actually
have synchronous audio
across multiple rooms.
Again, we'll do that on
behalf of the developer.
So it makes it really
simple and easy
to make a really compelling
killer use cases.
Now the other area
we've been looking
at is really about
how do we think
about multi-screen experiences?
The amazing thing about
having the phone connected
to these home
entertainment devices
is it's not just a
one way transaction.
It doesn't have to be hey,
I'm listening to content here.
I want to send it
to another device.
But you can actually have
the devices work together.
So how do we make that
a compelling experience?
How do we unlock that
capability for developers?
Well, last IO we launched a
capability called the Remote
Display APIs.
And we focus it
initially on gaming
because we believe that has
a really compelling use case.
And the idea here is can we take
advantage of the most powerful
computing device that most
people have in their homes
today, which turns out to
be their mobile device.
So what we do is we take
advantage of the GPU And CPU.
And the phone itself
will render two screens.
One screen plays
locally and one screen
goes to the Chromecast
or the Android TV device.
And now you have two screens,
you can do two different UIs,
you can have a consumption
UI on the big screen
and a interactive
UI on the phone.
So now you can think of
multi-screen experiences.
right?
This breaks through
to how you can
think about how you actually
build an application itself.
And so we launched
this last-- we
launched the APIs in last IO.
And we have a whole
bunch of game companies
actually launch over the
last few months including
Angry Birds Go and WGT Golf.
And we're seeing
a lot more coming.
But the great thing is this
capability doesn't only
have to work with games.
If you remember, we
actually launched
Google Photo support
for Google Cast as well.
And actually that
uses these APIs.
The Photos app just
uses the big screen
to render the highest
quality image that you can.
And it has all the
navigation on the phone.
So you have this two
tiered experience.
It's a really simple development
model for developers.
And so we're super excited
to see what developers
can do with it now that
they start thinking
about a multi-screen experience
as a look about entertainment
in the home.
So that's Google Cast.
Now let's talk about Android TV.
So every Android TV
device, first of all,
includes Google Cast in it.
So that's part of the
actual platform itself.
But the idea of
Android TV was, again,
to take this rich operating
system we have with Android
and extend it to many devices
including televisions.
And we believe Android's
the de facto one.
It should be the
de facto one given
the presence around all
the different devices
in consumers' lives today.
And the great thing is it's
the same Android platform
that you have on your
other devices, which means
for developers the same SDK.
You can take your
existing mobile app
and actually bring it directly
to now television devices.
The great thing is with
some small modifications,
you can then optimize
for different screens.
Right?
So if you want to
build for phone,
you want to build for
tablet, you can build for TV.
With some small changes you can
actually optimize automatically
for all the different
screens in the users' lives.
And the other great
thing, it just
uses the exact same
Play Store mechanisms.
All your merchandising, and
all your billing and payments,
automatically come with you.
It's a really simple model.
We really thought through how
to make this really incredibly
easy for developers to
bring their applications
direct to TV.
Now, of course,
with Android TV, we
need to rethink the user
experience a little bit
in terms of how do we
make it TV centric.
So this is the home screen
of an Android TV device.
And you'll see a couple things.
One is that it's content
centric versus purely
being app centric.
We want to bring content
to the foreground.
So we have this
recommendation shelf.
This is actually just a Android
TV API that any developer can
plug into to actually
showcase here's
content I want to
recommend to a consumer.
So, there is
paradigms we developed
to make it really
simple and easy
for a developer to
integrate, but also
make it more of a consumer
experience optimized
for television.
And we also have
universal search
built as part of
this product as well.
And the great thing is from
a developer standpoint,
we've tried to really make it
simple to take existing apps
and then optimize it for the TV.
We don't want to have to
make you rewrite everything
to make it work.
And so we have some
simple paradigms.
This is from the
Leanback Library.
And we have these
things called fragments
where you can just publish
your content into a fragment,
and we'll render it in
a really high quality,
beautiful way on the TV screen.
This is called the
Browse fragment.
So I encourage everyone
to take a look.
It's really simple to
actually bring your app,
depending on how much you
want to actually optimize it.
But we can give
you some paradigms
to make it really simple
and easy to do it.
And lastly, a different
approach to gaming
is obviously using
a remote control.
And so Android TV tries to
bring all the gaming paradigms
that we have in Android and also
brings them to the television.
So now you can run
a game which has
a traditional remote control
directly on the big screen.
And again, using
similar paradigms
I just talked about with Android
TV or Android in general.
So that's a quick summary
of the living room
strategy from Google.
We're looking at to
great platforms that
allow us to actually bring
experiences to consumers.
A mobile first approach,
which is about extending
your existing mobile app.
And the Android TV approach,
a TV centric approach,
where you can take your app and
optimize it for the big screen.
We're super excited to see
what you guys will do next.
OK, with that I'll head
it back to Timothy.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you, Rishi.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, let's
continue our conversation
with the senior US designer on
Android Wear, Krystal Higgins.
[APPLAUSE]
KRYSTAL HIGGINS:
Thanks, Timothy.
And hi everyone.
Thank you for joining us on
the second day of Ubiquity.
I am personally very
excited to be here
because I have been working on
Android Wear and Android Wear
watches since the
day I joined Google.
Because I personally believe
that wearables are the most
versatile and the most
personal connected objects
we can have the pleasure
of designing for.
In a few moments, I'm going
to share with you some
of the new ways
that we have enabled
you to build great wearable
experiences for Android Wear.
But first, I want to add just
a layer of context around what
we're trying to do here.
This might be a bit
of refresher for some,
but it's an important
foundation that will
anchor what I talk about next.
So this is the kind of situation
that we're solving for.
I don't need to remind you
or tell you how awesome,
how great and useful mobile
phones and tablets can
be in our everyday lives.
There are great
use cases for them.
But Google's also
been looking into ways
to use technology so
that we can actually
be just a bit more connected
to the world around us,
even while being more connected
virtually to those people who
are not with us.
And it's Android Wear that
aims to complete that picture
by giving you useful
information at a glance,
but letting you stay in the
moment when it's appropriate.
And this becomes clearer if we
break this down in a bit more
of a visual manner.
Right?
This might be a day
with your phone.
Notice the length
of time it can take
to get your phone out, unlock
it, navigate to where you
need to go, and engage with it.
And there are
certainly times when
it's great to get
lost in your phone.
Right?
Maybe you're on a commute
or waiting in line.
But there's also a hefty
time and attention cost
if all you really
wanted to do was just
check some bit of information
or feel slightly connected when
you're out with friends.
Now if we look at the
same set of interactions
on a wearable
device, then we can
see that there's a reduced
overhead per interaction.
We can actually help you be more
physically present in the world
around you, even
while being more
connected to the virtual one.
And what this means for
developing user experiences
on these watches is
that we just have
to think a little
bit differently
about what we build.
Because it's a fundamentally
different interaction model.
And you can tell just by
looking at some of the watches,
they're fundamentally different
than other mobile devices.
So we have to
rethink it a bit when
considering which features
of your service or your app
you want to bring to the wrist.
It's really about
thinking what couldn't we
do on the mobile
app before that we
can now extend, that we can
now make possible in the wrist.
For example, Google Fit
has a great mobile app
that helps you keep track
of your fitness goals
throughout the day, the
week, or even the month.
But the watch doesn't
need all that information.
It is positioned in a way that
it can give you experiences
that the mobile app can't-- like
to track repetitions as you do
things like push ups or squats.
Things that weren't possible
before, but a natural extension
of the app that
existed on the phone.
So with Android
Wear watches, you
can bring things to the
watch that you haven't
been able to do with
the phone before, more
meaningful experiences.
And our philosophy for how to
design for Android Wear apps
is all anchored and
inspired by something
that we've done with
watches for a long time.
Right?
Telling the time.
It's a simple action.
You glance at your wrist, you
get the information you need,
and you make a decision
in fractions of a second.
Its glanceable, it's
actionable, and it's effortless.
And these create the
cornerstone for how
we think about designing
for Android Wear apps
and how we have extended our
platform support to enable
you to do the same.
Since day one we've
made it so that apps
can provide glanceable,
actionable, and effortless
experiences on the watch
with notification bridging.
If your apps send notifications,
they will automatically
synchronize with Android Wear.
If you use media APIs,
you'll get that for free.
But it's the Android
Wear experiences
that go beyond the
notification layer
to deliver something more
uniquely wearable that actually
are more successful.
So ever since we launched
with notification support,
we've been extending
the platform,
growing it so that we can
give you more opportunities
to create those great
meaningful wearable experiences.
You have the ability to
leverage sensors from heart rate
monitors to accelerometers,
haptic motors, and microphones.
We enabled Wi-Fi support
in May and introduced
wearable friendly interaction
methods like emoji recognition
and wrist gestures.
And we've continued to grow our
watch portfolio so that there
will always be a watch
that fits your users
and their unique needs.
So when you build
for Android Wear,
you know that the
opportunities to create
meaningful experiences will
only get better over time.
And there's actually
two recent features
that I want to call out as
providing you with the means
to create the right wearable
experience for your app
or service's unique use case.
First, with Android
Wear watches,
you have the ability to create
always on app experiences.
And you can now marry
aesthetics with utility
with interactive watch faces.
As a designer, I'm
really inspired
by these ones, excited by them.
Because these give
you the options
you need to cover a
whole slew of use cases
that you might run into.
Now, Android Wear watches
are unique in their ability
to have screens on 24 hours
a day, seven days a week
without user
interaction required.
And we can do all of this
while also saving on battery.
Never before in the
history of computing
have we had this opportunity
to have so many always on,
always accessible screens.
So we should be taking
advantage of it.
Now we started by enabling
always on experiences
with the watch face level.
We figured that hey, when
people choose a watch face,
it's a personal choice.
It's a style choice.
And so it should always be
represented in some manner.
The screen shouldn't
just go black.
So we made it so
that the watch face
would display in a
low power ambient mode
when the watch was not in use.
And we quickly
realized that there
were great app activities
that would benefit
from the same kind of behavior.
The watch didn't always have
to go back to this low power
state of the watch face.
So we made that
available for you.
You can now create always on app
activities for ongoing sessions
when that information
is necessary.
So let's look at a few examples
of ways that you can use this.
Shopping, a great example.
I might create a shopping
list while I'm at work.
But when I get to the store
I want to put it on my wrist
so that it's easily
accessible and readable as I
go through various aisles.
Now I can do things like
check off vegetables
when I get to that
aisle, interact with it
for a split second.
But even as I'm busy going
through the rest of the store,
it will go into a low
power black and white state
so that it's always visible
for as long as I need it.
Maps, navigation.
That's another great use case.
I might be exploring
a new neighborhood.
So I want to put maps
directions on my wrist,
but I don't want to
constantly be looking at it.
With this always on capability,
maps are always available to me
while I need it
without me needing
to fiddle with the watch
or tap on the watch face.
It's just a glance away.
And fitness, as well,
I do a lot of workouts.
And I like having my workout
stats available to me.
But I don't need my
watch to be constantly
in an interactive,
full color state.
I can save on
battery while still
get the information I need,
all while it's relevant to me.
So these always
on app experiences
are great because they don't
require you to be interacting
with the watch to get
the information you
need at the time you can.
You can provide to your
users the experiences
that give them the information
they need at any given moment.
And it's great for session based
activities or ongoing sessions.
Now, complementary to
always on experiences
is that we are allowing you
to build interactive watch
faces for those times
when you want information
to be accessible, but
that don't need to be
tied to an ongoing app session.
Since late 2014, you've been
able to create your own watch
faces and maybe
some of you have.
They are a great way to provide
that perpetual information
at a glance without requiring
people to open an app.
Now, as watch faces
evolved, after we
made this capability
available to you all,
we noticed people building
rich complications,
really informative watch
faces, to the extent
that people were tapping
on them, expecting
another layer of interaction.
So we recognized that need and
made that accessible to you.
Now you can bubble
up key actions
into the watch face that
are just a tap away.
And we can see this if
we look at a few examples
like this interactive
watch face called Bits.
It shows me, well, bits of
information about my day
so I can see my day at a glance.
But any time I want a
deeper level of context,
all I have to do is tap on
one of those complications.
I can see the next hour
in the weather forecast,
or exactly who I'm meeting
with in the next 50 minutes,
all without feeling like I've
ever left the watch face.
And in this example
from the Moto 360 Sport,
I can have my fitness stats
ongoing, present on my watch
face all day long in
an ambient manner.
But at any time I can tap
on one of these sections
to get a deeper look
at my steps count.
Or I can go ahead
and decide that it's
time to start a workout.
And I have that shortcut
right from the watch face.
So again, with always on apps,
and with interactive watch
faces, we're giving
you the tools
you need to provide the right
experience to your users
at the right time.
And also great about
building for Android Wear
is that you can reach
people, no matter
what their style, taste,
or their fashion sense.
Right?
We have a number of watches that
we make available to consumers.
So there's always going to
be a device, a watch, that
fits your users and their
unique lifestyle needs.
And we released new
devices this fall
and also announced three
new ones last week.
And when you build
for Android Wear,
you will also have
the opportunity
to have global reach.
We have support in 42
countries and language pairs.
And this is all on the
platform that you're already
familiar with.
You can take 99%
of your knowledge
about building for Android
and apply it to Android Wear.
And in fact, today, you
can do more and learn more
about how to build these
experiences with some
of the sessions that
we have going on.
We have some great
sessions after lunch.
Talks specifically on how to
build always on experiences
and interactive watch faces.
Starting at 2, we
have office hours.
And we have code labs all day.
So you can try Android
Wear and talk to us.
Ask us questions.
And if you need
other resources, we
have a community on
Google Plus as well as
our developer website where you
can get articles, tutorials,
and more.
So I look forward to
seeing what you build.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
All right, we have
one more product
to discuss with you today.
And that's Android Auto.
So I'd like to welcome
product manager Daniel
Holle to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL HOLLE:
Thank you, Timothy.
Hi, I'm Daniel Holle.
I'm product manager
on Android Auto.
And I want to show you
today a little bit about how
the future of apps could
look like in the car.
A couple years back,
we looked at where
Android is used the most.
And we found that
a lot of people
are using Android in their
cars while they're driving.
Actually 100 million Americans
spend more than one hour a day
in the car.
That's a lot of potential
for a true digital experience
in the car.
Of course, many people
use their trusted devices,
their smartphones,
bring them into the car,
and use them while driving.
We talked to users and
they told us this is
a really cumbersome experience.
Right?
You have to focus on
two different things.
The phone layout is not
really optimized for the car.
And it's also actually
really, really unsafe
to do that while driving.
Actually 25% of the accidents
in the US involve a smartphone.
And this is really
not how we imagine
a great experience in the car.
So we felt we really
needed to fix this.
So we set out to build
with Android Auto
to build a safer and better
user experience in the car.
We wanted to have the product
be focused around your phone.
The phone is really
the central piece
of user's digital experience.
We always have it with us and
it carries are very personal
information on there.
We designed the product
so you can plug your phone
into the car via USB cable.
And it then takes
over the big display
that you have in your car.
We also tie in touchscreen
controls, rotary controllers,
and steering wheel controls
so you can actually control
your apps on the screen.
The apps still run on the phone.
And that's the
beautiful thing about it
because we can
update the product.
And you can update
your apps on the phone
just as we used to do
through the Play Store.
So there's no trip to the
dealer required to update
the in-car experience.
You just update your apps
and they just work in the car
as well.
So we put a lot
of work into this.
And nearly a year ago,
we launched Android Auto.
And I have a video that
I want to share with you
about the product we built.
HENRY NEWTON-DUNN: Cars
are integral to the way
that people live
their lives today.
We use cars for taking
our kids to school.
We use our cars for
commuting to work.
But when we look at cars
today, they're fundamentally
disconnected vehicles.
PATRICK BRADY: People
don't want to check
their phones at the door when
they get behind the wheel.
So we partnered with auto
manufacturers and technology
partners to figure
out the best way
to bring Android into the car.
Today we're announcing Android
Auto, which extends the Android
platform into the car.
Android Auto combines
the best of both worlds.
You get the connected apps and
services on your smartphone
with the physical controls
that were optimized
for driving in your car.
We had to go back
to the drawing board
and really take
an experience that
was designed for a
smartphone and break it down
to its bare essential.
HENRY NEWTON-DUNN: We focused
it down to the features
that the user really needs
within the driving space.
We've made Google Maps really
easy to use for the car.
We've got nice, easy to access
touch targets and a simplified
interface.
The voice technology that
we're using within the car
is super conversational.
PATRICK BRADY: Your
hands are on the wheel,
your eyes are on the road.
MALE SPEAKER: Set a reminder
to get gas on the way
back to work.
Pick up my dry cleaning.
Remind me to get
tickets on the way home.
PATRICK BRADY: Google brings
you just the right information
at just the right time.
So when you set reminders
while you're driving,
your phone will
remind you later on
even if you're outside the car.
Android developers will soon
be able to create entirely
new experiences for the car.
HENRY NEWTON-DUNN: We're really
excited about this opportunity
because for us, this is really
very much at the beginning.
And you know, we're
really going to go
on a long journey with this.
DANIEL HOLLE: So
this is actually
a really amazing product.
This will change the way we
experience our time in the car.
We showed this to a lot of OEMs,
the car manufacturing industry.
And they were really
excited about it.
Since we launched this, the
Open Automotive Alliance
has been growing.
And we have nearly
every manufacturer
around the world
now working with us
to bring this to their car
models and to users out there.
So they gave us lots of
backing for this product.
In 2016, we will continue this
great momentum in several ways.
There will be more
cars hitting the road.
We have about 10 cars,
models, out there right now.
And there will be 40
more coming this year.
This will really bring the
reach to a lot of users.
There's also more countries.
We launched with a
couple countries.
But this year, we
are really extending
it to be a global
reach of Android Auto.
And there are more
apps coming to Android.
Today, we have more than 500
apps enabled for Android Auto.
And this is actually
the part that I'm
most excited about is the app
developer ecosystem that we
can finally bring to the car.
You know, before Android Auto it
was really cumbersome and hard
for developers to
build for cars.
You had several different
car operating systems,
different models, different
screen sizes, different input
methods to your apps.
And that made it really
hard for developers
to get reach across cars and
across models and regions.
So I'm glad that we solved
this part for app developers.
Because today, you
actually have one platform,
one single platform to
build for across car models
and across countries.
And this gives you
the fundamental reach
that you need for
your apps in the car.
And the good news
is it's Android.
So if you have an
existing Android app,
it's really simple to just
enable that app for Android
Auto and play in the car.
So let me give you in a nutshell
how this could work for you.
We focused on the
core driving use cases
and have an SDK
ready for media apps.
So now apps like music,
podcasts, audio book players
can be enabled in the
car to extend the user
experience on their display.
And this is a great use case to
stay entertained while you're
driving in a safe way.
The APIs that we have available
can help to expose your content
in a menu structure, can
use your customized playback
controls.
And you can adjust the UI to
really communicate your brand
still on the car screen.
It is really-- I'd
have to say-- it's
a very special magic moment
when you get in the car,
you plug in your phone, and you
see your personalized playlists
on the big screen.
And you can just continue
playing your music
that you just heard
before on your phone.
The second SDK is
the messaging SDK.
This is geared towards
messaging and chat apps
to come to the
Android Auto screen.
Again, a very dominant
use case because we
all want to stay
connected and communicate
while we're on our commutes.
This messaging SDK gives you
the ability through those APIs
to show notifications if an
incoming message is there.
It gives you the potential to
play back that message that's
being read out to you.
And you can actually
reply via speech to it.
And it works really well.
I use it on my commute with
several different messengers
and it's a great experience
to stay connected in the car.
And again, we really make
it safer through that.
So you keep your hands
on the steering wheel,
your eyes on the road, and you
can still chat back and forth.
Just imagine how much we
make our users' lives safer
with implementing this
SDK and bringing messaging
to the car in a safe way.
So I want to share a little
bit about the road ahead.
Of course, we don't stop here.
We work fiercely to
get into more use cases
and to approve the existing
SDKs on the product.
The improvements
that are on the way
are, for example, for the media
SDK, to expose more content.
We have safety
regulations that we
adhere to to make it safe
how to browse your content.
And we're working
on ways to expose
more content, your full set of
playlists for the media SDK.
We also bring innovative car OEM
apps to Android Auto this year.
Car manufacturers will
have the opportunity
to build their own apps and
use cases for Android Auto.
And we'll also launch more
app categories in 2016
to the developer community.
So with this platform,
we really believe
we can build a better and safer
user experience for the car.
And with the SDK too, you can
participate in this mission.
So I would really like to invite
you to enable your Android Auto
apps, your apps for
Android Auto today,
and join this mission to
make our users' lives safer
and a better
experience in the car.
Thank you very much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Timothy.
Thank you, Daniel.
So, I hope you all got
your toolboxes yesterday.
Most of you?
OK.
We noticed that there was a
little extra room in them.
So we thought we'd give
you something else that
was discussed today
to build for those.
And that will be both a
Chromecast and a Chromecast
Audio.
[APPLAUSE]
So you'll be able to pick
these up at the afternoon break
later in the day.
And thank you very much for
having a really great day
one at the Ubiquity Dev Summit.
And let's make it
a great day two.
Learning together how to build
beyond the internet of things.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]